when I was a young officer they told me
to follow my instincts to go with my gut
and what I've learned is that often our
instincts are wrong in the summer of
2010 there was a massive leak of
classified documents that came out of
the Pentagon it shocked the world it
shook up the American government and it
made people ask a lot of questions
because the mere amount of information
that was let out and the potential
impacts were significant now one of the
first questions we asked ourselves was
why would a young soldier have access to
that much information why would we let
sensitive things be with a relatively
young person in the summer of 2003 I was
assigned to command a Special Operations
task force and that task force has
spread across the Mideast to fight al
Qaeda our main effort was inside Iraq
and our specified mission was to defeat
al-qaeda in Iraq for almost five years I
stayed there and we focused on fighting
a war that was unconventional and it was
difficult and it was bloody and it often
claimed its highest price among innocent
people we did everything we could to
stop al Qaeda and the foreign fighters
that came in as suicide bombers and his
accelerants of the violence we honed our
combat skills we developed new equipment
we parachuted we helicoptered we took
small boats we drove and we walk to
objectives night after night to just
stop the killing that this network was
putting forward we bled
we died and we killed to stop that
organization from the violence that they
were putting largely against the Iraqi
people now we did what we knew how we
had grown up and one of the things that
we knew that was in our DNA was secrecy
who was security was protecting
information it was the idea that
information was the lifeblood and it was
what would protect and keep people safe
and we had a sense that as we operated
within our organizations it was
important to keep information in the
silos within the organizations
particularly only give information to
people who had a demonstrated need to
know but the question often came who
need to know who needed who had to have
the information so they could do the
important parts of the job that you
needed in an in tightly coupled world
that's very hard to predict it's very
hard to know who needs to have
information and who doesn't I used to
deal with intelligence agencies and I'd
complain that they weren't sharing
enough intelligence and with a straight
face they'd look at me and they'd say
what aren't you getting I said if I knew
that we wouldn't have a problem but what
we found is we had to change we had to
change our culture about information we
had and knock down the walls we had to
share we had to change from who needs to
know to the fact that who doesn't know
and we need to tell and tell them as
quickly as we can
it was a significant culture shift for
an organization that had secrecy in its
DNA we started by doing things by
building not working in offices knocking
down walls working in things we called
situational awareness rooms and in the
summer of 2007 something happened which
demonstrated this we captured the
personnel records for the people who
were bringing foreign fighters into Iraq
and when we got the personnel records
typically we would have hidden these
shared them with a few intelligence
agencies and then tried to operate with
them but as I was talking to my
intelligence officer I said what do we
do and he said well you found them I
command you can just declassify them and
I said well can we declassify them what
if the enemy finds out he says they're
their personnel records so we did now a
lot of people got upset about that but
as we pass that information around
suddenly you find that information is
only a value if you give it to people
and the ability to do something with it
the fact that I know something has zero
value if I'm not the person who can
actually make something better because
of it so as a consequence what we did is
we change the idea of information
instead of knowledge is power to one
we're sharing his power
it was the fundamental shift not new
tactics not new weapons not new anything
else it was the idea that we were now
part of a team which information became
the essential link between us not a
block between us now I want everybody to
sort of take a deep breath and let it
out because in your life there's going
to be information that leaks out you're
not gonna like somebody's going to get
my college grades out and that's going
to be a disaster but it's going to be ok
and I will tell you that I am more
scared of the bureaucrat that holds
information in a desk drawer or a safe
than I am of someone who leaks because
ultimately we'll be better off if we
share thank you
I don't know if you were here this
morning if you were able to catch Rick
legit the deputy director of the NSA who
was responding to Edward Snowden's talk
earlier this week I just wonder do you
think the American government should
give Edward Snowden amnesty I think that
Rick said something very important we
most people don't know all the facts I
think there are two parts of this Edward
Snowden shined a light on an important
need that people had to understand he
also took a lot of documents that he
didn't have the knowledge to know the
importance of so I think we need to
learn the facts about this case before
we make snap judgments about hundreds
stone thank you so much thank you